[Music]
i'm gonna paraphrase but this was asked
a ton of times which is how would you
start again from zero i hate this
question i don't ever answer this
question i'm like that's an impossible
thing to answer because you're just
looking for like a spoon fed thing um
and you're just not going to do whatever
we say does i mean
if you're asking that question you're
probably not going to do it okay but
still answer it what what answer it the
way you want which is maybe you're not
spoon feeding a specific answer but like
dude what does a guy like sam do in a
day and age like this let's put it there
differently well and i also don't like
this question because the answer is
i would do exactly the same thing again
sean perry is
how's it going is it working wonderfully
it's working amazing it feels great to
be sampar at age 24 or however you old
you were when you started this
i would do the exact same thing it
totally works if you pick the right
niche you but here's the thing is like
you care about this topic i cared about
my topic which they were related but not
the same you don't mind writing every
day i didn't mind either and so i would
do the same thing the only thing that
you did differently was that you were
already kind of famous and you had this
huge twitter following which definitely
helped i had a ten thousand person email
list from hustlecon so i had a little
bit of a base and we're both doing the
exact same thing you get make sure you
have content market fit and so which
means you see if you can uh
create a newsletter every single day
which both of us have done you cr find a
way to get traffic in my case it was by
blogging in your case it's twitter and
then once you realize that that works
then you i would buy ads which you are
now doing i think and i did do and you
scale and you find out what your ltv is
and then you just figure out how much
you want to spend and then you go and
get advertisers you're already making
like a lot of money every month doing
this
and you're like great
four months in it took me two years to
get to where you are
well that's because i saw the blueprint
right like i wouldn't have even known
this could even make any like when you
first told me
you're like yeah email newsletter um i
think you make a bunch of money and then
i was like by doing what like email's
free with f what are you talking about
this was there wasn't like sub stack
didn't exist it wasn't even i didn't
know of any paid newsletter
and i didn't even really real i didn't
even realize there's like a newsletter
advertising industry and if you had told
me that i would be like oh cool like
might as well have said you're gonna go
sell buttons at a flea market like right
it doesn't seem like that big of an idea
and then you're like yeah you can make
and i think you had told me at the time
100 cpm which i don't think turned out
to be true but like no i i think i said
50 maybe but that is true yeah i don't
remember what i said but whatever i said
it was ridiculous yeah you never said
100 and then i was like so wait a minute
so you're like a list of ten thousand
people and like wait what's the cpm i
was like oh god gotta do math and then i
like but like when i ended up at a
number i was like so wait if you sent
that every day you just make that much
money every day and i remember just
being like well okay maybe this is
actually an awesome idea instead of like
you know a kind of shitty idea
but that's only one of the ways that it
can make money
right which is what you're seeing you're
seeing that that's just the tip of the
iceberg and you're only on the tip yeah
yeah just the tip as we like to say
business
do you see how this could scale to 100
million in sales maybe maybe not this is
by the way not a q a we're just giving
tips and this is just the tip the
justices
it's a short podcast so we can only do
just the tip
uh
do you see how this could scale to 100
million in sales
yeah i think you know probably for more
than just ads but yeah for for sure yeah
and i think so okay one general idea of
what you're saying is basically
if you are good at content
it is possible to build a large con
content audience
and then you that that is the door that
opens more doors so either you use that
to like
you know like what i did with my
following at first was i launched a fund
i was like great investing is a cool way
to make money
first built an audience and then
launched a fund and the audience became
my investors i took zero meetings i did
zero pitched calls or whatever and
raised a multi-million dollar fund
from just the audience so that's like
the superpower of an audience so i i
think that's one thing you could do
which is already a like potentially an
eight-figure thing for you uh at worst
maybe seven figures but like that's like
already monetizing you don't get that
today but in the future and the the
other thing uh by the way is that uh
then by the way the next question is how
well how how would you build an audience
who started from scratch like that's a
that's the next that's next question
which you probably is like your second
most hated question yeah i hate that
okay so that's it's like don't ask a
girl her weight or don't ask samfar what
he would do to build audience from
scratch if he started just don't like it
because it's like dude you're asking me
on twitter you see what i do yeah that's
that's actually my middle lesson okay so
can i can i do my rant for a second here
yeah um which is kind of a buzz kill for
the just the tip episode but let me let
me do it anyways
most of the people who ask that question
i don't want to answer not because it's
not a good question but because
if you're asking that question that
basically means you're not going to do
it you're not going to do it because the
answer is so obvious it's already out
there everybody who's building an
audience is doing it super publicly so
all you have to do is be like okay so
this guy does it this way and this girl
does it that way and this guy does it
this way and like then you sort of just
bucket it you're like okay seems like
you kind of need to just choose one
medium like maybe podcasting or twitter
or email they all have different
benefits and then like on that medium
you need to like maybe pick a topic and
that's your theme you become the the guy
who always talks about frameworks or the
guy who talks about crypto or the guy
who always talks about business ideas or
whatever it is and then you can expand
once you already have a base exactly and
then like you should try to get the you
start to make viral content because it's
going to get shared a bunch you can kind
of like get sponsors and turn that money
into like buying out like it's so
obvious what all of us are doing
that if you if you if you don't know how
to do it at this point like you failed
the iq test and i don't mean that to be
mean i just mean it like to me you're
not serious about the question
um yeah because the answer is already
like visible to you and if and i think
there's some like more nuanced questions
like which platform would you pick today
would you pick email or twitter or
whatever like i think there's different
questions that might be slightly better
questions um but the generic one is
pretty bad and this is how i rant so
last night
i'm watching tick tock i try open tick
tock as i do
for my tic-tacs basically like my
bedtime story and um
and i see this guy on there and he's
like some like
sean connery looking guy and he's like
this like kind of like complete gray
beard guy and he's cooking an egg so
he's like the perfect
that he cooked the perfect egg let's do
it and he's like you know he's like we
got eggs we got black salt we have this
like you know i know he's got like what
looks like just like a branch with
leaves on it and that's probably
something like seasoning he's like you
know we have these things okay cool turn
the pan to high heat crack the eggs put
the eggs in
now we're gonna like keep it on high you
know you have your oil
you have it on high and you're trying to
get this crust he's like how do you know
when there's a crust watch this jiggle
it and like so he's he's like literally
teaching you in like a 30 second format
how to cook the perfect eggs and by the
end he like takes that out of the pan
you're like dude i just want to try that
egg more than anything in my life right
now
and it had 10 million views had 10
million views and like all the comments
are like you know be my dad and like you
know i'll marry you if you cook me these
eggs every morning and he like cuts into
it the egg yolk starts running and it's
cur like it's crispy on the bottom and
soft on top it's like just looks amazing
right and it got me thinking i was like
he made it look so simple i saw the egg
crack right so
um
you know i saw what he did it wasn't
like that complicated he explained every
step of what he was doing and there's
like 10 million likes on this video
which means like a lot of people have
seen this video
i thought how many people are going to
cook an egg like this so how many people
are even going to try to cook an egg
like this
how many people could actually cook the
egg like this after watching it and it's
got me thinking i was like you know
when i watch this video of this guy
telling me how to do it
it seems all simple enough but i know if
i walk to my stove right now and i took
the two eggs and the salt and the pan
with the oil
my egg is not going to turn out like
that right like i would need
a lot of reps to be able to ever cook an
egg the way the guy did it and he showed
me the exact formula he told me the
formula
and it got me thinking about business
advice i go
this is the problem with twitter and
even podcasts like this which is that
imagine now that i watch that video of
that egg and then tomorrow i come on and
there's another video of like this guy
cooking eggs and then there's like the
next day there's another one and like
maybe the next day the guys when you're
gonna go make your own damn egg exactly
and like after six months i would kind
of in my heart i would feel like dude i
know how to cook eggs but again if i
walked to a stove and i tried to do it i
would make a runny mess and it would be
horrible
and like the problem with twitter and
the problem with the people with the way
that people use twitter and use podcasts
is
they get on every day
and they just watch other people cook
eggs they watch guys like you and me
cook eggs
like we we don't listen to them anybody
but we record our own right like right
we are happy to take your attention well
it's like they uh they're just
masturbating instead of having sex
exactly exactly and like but you
convince yourself like i could just
imagine if i had done this for six
months i'd be like dude i know
everything there is to know about
cooking eggs and that's that same person
who's on twitter who reads advice from
every investor and founder who's
tweeting out their you know three ways
to you know three of my the biggest
mistakes i made before 30 a thread you
know my six hiring mistakes about
managers a thread um you know like all
these things right like it's like when i
ask my daughter when we play this game i
say who's your best friend she goes the
floor that's how i feel about the thread
you know like basically it's like here
just i'm gonna say this arbitrary [__]
and like i can imagine
that if you
listen to that and read that every day
you would think you are learning how to
cook eggs
but you have no idea how to cook eggs
even after reading all of that in fact
you almost are worse off than somebody
who just tried to cook eggs for two
weeks straight and then maybe in the on
the 14th day
of cooking their eggs they go on twitter
and they see something they're like oh
that's how i should change the way i'm
cracking the egg because like you know
how the heat is too high oh that's it
okay let me go back and make an
adjustment and so
my rant is basically
don't be the dude who just watches the
video of cooking eggs like go crack some
eggs make a bunch of mistakes and then
come back to twitter and podcast like
this for your just in time learning to
like just give you a tweak on the thing
you're actually doing right right right
right i i'm i'm on board i completely
agree with everything you said
you want to do uh let's go back to
answering some questions yeah from
people let us watch us crack some eggs
all right you pick one you pick one and
then i'll pick one and so forth okay
sounds good uh let's do this first one
so what are the key traits you look for
in a co-founder and
red flags so that your business is
successful and you guys stay happy
and i think you've had like multiple
co-founders i think right
ish i was always like the guy and then
like i had first people that were more
batman robin
yeah yeah yeah um and but then with joe
spicer for my fund that's 50 50. uh the
and what i've learned number one uh they
have to be emotionally healthy and very
emotionally stable i would consider
myself to be mostly stable on the big
things but my mood goes up and down and
for me to be a good partner with someone
they need to be emotionally stable even
if i was like really stable it's really
important because i've seen a lot of
like it's just like the same way you
ever have like a friend that's got like
a husband or a wife and they're just
[__] crazy and it's like i don't know
how to advise you here like this person
is acting irrational like it's really
challenging it's like you want to
separate them like you stop acting crazy
and you stop acting crazy that's my only
advice to both of you guys
yeah it's like dude this is this is just
it's not going to work out and so i
married a woman that was like very
stable and even keel and i realized oh
that's perfect so what i look for in
partners is people who are emotionally
stable uh and and i also want a partner
that's incredibly honest and undersells
themselves uh i also and if i find out
that they lie at all like even on small
[__] it's game over for me so really
high integrity is important um and then
finally having really high energy so
like who can just like who wants to push
the pace and uh basically with my best
partners i feel intimidated and inspired
by them
that's a great way of putting it and i
think it shows like i'm pretty chill
sarah is very chill
i don't know joe that well but he seems
also very chilly very chill you know
very cool your your partners basically
and your ventures are like you know
resting heart rate under 40. like it's
hard to get a heart rate up and like i
think that's good that's a good pair for
you yeah because i don't mind being the
high energy like i'm typically the one
that can be the catalyst and be the
igniter right and then a person that
wants to be the guider i enjoy right
yeah that's that's a great one there's
this book that i read called why you
will marry the wrong person have you
read that by uh tim urban no no he has a
it's the school he's a blog post called
that oh yeah you're right you're right
school of life so the in it like the
very first principles like we marry the
wrong person because
um you know one of the things that says
like we don't even know how we are crazy
everybody's nuts
you just if you but if you don't
recognize how you're nuts
um you're not gonna know how to pick a
partner who could deal with your level
your version of crazy and you're gonna
have to deal with their version of crazy
and the idea that you're gonna change
them to not be so crazy is like not a
thing like everybody's weird or you just
don't know them well enough so like you
got to have your you got to know your
weirdness is and then be like cool is
this person compatible fundamentally
compatible with my my type of weird uh
that's kind of a version of what you
just said so what what are yours
so i kind of steal from like you know
warren buffett said this thing and then
i think paraphrase it as well which is
like
two things you just said energy
integrity and intelligence so those
those three so break them down um
energy is the one i think most people
overlook i think everybody wants
intelligence they're like oh yeah i want
somebody who's like really smart or
really good right it's like yeah that's
that's true you don't want to you don't
want somebody who's incompetent it'll
drive you nuts in the long run i've had
that problem before
you don't want somebody who's low
integrity right because a smart person
is low integrity is a crook it's just a
matter of return until they screw you
and then the last one is
energy and the energy thing i think is
the one that everybody overlooks i put
it as my number one which is like some
people call it vibe some people call it
energy i call it mood you know whatever
it's basically does this person
bring enthusiasm by default or are they
always looking for something like do
they need an excuse to be high energy do
they need an excuse to be motivated do
they need an excuse to be optimistic and
enthusiastic about what you're working
on because if they if they do you're
gonna i feel like i'm constantly like a
doctor with the shock paddles like all
right clear give me you know give me
give me 20 amps or whatever and like
just trying to like get them to be like
yo wake up and i i've had this with like
business meetings because
ben who's my business partner on all my
different businesses ben's a very
low-key guy he's very low low he comes
acro he's not actually low energy but
his speaking style is low energy and so
sometimes we'll be in meetings and i'd
just be like guys i just don't want to
ever be in a meeting that feels like
this right now like nobody's fighting
but like also nobody's saying anything
like hello wake up like
you know do you care are you there do
you have ideas or are you just
creatively bankrupt and like i just
don't want to be in a room that's like
low energy so can we just shake that up
right now and they're like oh yeah sorry
um
let's [__] go like they give me some
token thing i'm like it's fine even a
token thing is fine it shows that you
understand what matters to me
i was going to say the two people i
think do actually have good
who show that i was both of our ben so
ben uh our ben here ben wilson he has
good energy and vibe because whenever
i'm around him i feel happier and i
leave happier right uh and he does a
good job of matching and then ben levy
is uh whenever same thing whenever i'm
around him i feel happier and he also uh
gets a lot of energy talking to people
which is which i [__] hate doing so
ben levy's a great partner yeah he's
amazing uh he's really amazing um okay
so that's kind of what i guess i
answered that question um which one do
you want to do next
okay let's do this one um what did you
tell your friend on twitter so okay
question is what it what did you tell
your friend on twitter that resulted in
his audience's growth to 100k in just a
few hours
um
so he tweeted i helped him write another
one today did you see it no no is it pop
it off oh yeah right away it got like
five or ten it got five or ten thousand
likes in the first 30 minutes and it's
already reached five million people okay
so explain the thought process how did
you alright what advice did you give
them that would help them do that
people hate this advice but look here it
is the guy made a hundred million
dollars in the nhl and he spent 20 years
being a hockey player
and i'm just helping him craft some of
the stories that he's already lived so
step one is there's this massive unfair
advantage which is he's he's lived in
he's lived an interesting life yeah and
i was talking to my friend logan who has
this book called how to not die alone
and she's like a dating coach and helps
uh men and women find partners and i was
talking to her about how i think men
should find dates and i'm like you know
the best thing about being able to
attract a woman is as long as you focus
on yourself and live an interesting life
and constantly improve yourself that's
what women really care about and that's
really it goes beyond women so with
chris it was like well you just live an
interesting life are you are you looking
at his tweet
right now so it says first tweet is
when you hear about x player making 30
million over five years six million
dollars a year you think wow he made it
however that's not always the reality in
this field i'm going to break down how
much they take home and where the rest
of it goes
i'm curious tell me more yeah
what's the result so far
uh so it has 10 000 likes it was posted
five hours ago
wow so um so with chris what i do is i
basically
uh talk to him on the phone and he's
like hey i've got this idea where i want
to talk about like finances and he'll
like he'll have a conversation with me
for 20 minutes and i'll say he'll say
yeah you know it's crazy about escrow
and i'm like wait hold on what the hell
is escrow he goes yeah so like basically
when you get paid 30 goes into escrow
and i was like oh so when you get that
money back he was you actually never get
that money back that money is used to
afford the lead the league and i'm like
oh that's interesting because yeah it's
no big deal so anyway and then like i'll
keep talking i'm like no no no no that's
the thing that's the thing and so when
what you have to do is you have to find
the big idea and you have to do this
thing called the
it's called like the knowledge complex
but basically if you wanted to get good
at twitter you've got to a live an
interesting life and b understand that
the interesting and unique experiences
in your life it's really not well known
to a bunch of people and you have to
realize that like what seems boring to
you isn't boring to most other people
and so you've got to figure out how to
tweet that and if you don't live an
interesting life go and live an
interesting one or go and learn about a
topic and just tweet everything you're
learning
exactly exactly i think you said it
perfectly i'll only add
one part to that which is
uh in in my power writing course i teach
this uh exercise and um basically i use
this i explained the exact same way you
said i said you have two choices like
fundamentally you can either be a
generous expert meaning you know
something so well you could just be
sharing it with an audience
or a curious novice curious beginner so
it's like you just say yo i don't know
anything about this but i'm curious i'm
going to dig in and find out if you want
to learn what i learned you know going
from zero to
understanding you know defy uh just
follow this threat a bunch of people
like great i'm also a dummy if you're
gonna do a bunch of work for this i
would love to hear what what your
takeaways are at the end and so people
vastly underestimate the curious
beginner path which almost is a better
path really um
because they think you have to be a
generous expert you think they think you
have to have played in the nhl made a
hundred million dollars in order to
share this type of info
um there's other formats like you know
meme king um yeah spicy analyst like i
have all these like names for these like
different
different like
lanes you can go down for content to win
but like those are those are two of them
let's say the other thing i say is
there's exercise because most people
like well you know i haven't made 100
million so what do i talk about
and so there's this exercise from the
book story worthy that i stole called
first last best worst have you ever done
this yeah you well you did it with me it
was great oh okay cool so we've done it
before but like basically let's just
play it again for people who don't don't
know it but like and we can pick maybe
even a different topic so
you take any category of your life so it
could be relationships it could be
colleges like um
it could be hustles yeah this could be
jobs so let's take jobs so what would be
sam parker's first job
janitor at a bakery
okay great didn't know that um
what was your uh worst job
um
i uh
staining decks in the summer in st louis
you're totally miserable doing okay
great
then uh what was your um what was your
best job
being a podcast host
and then what was your um
like let like say we usually say last
job but it means like most recent job so
like in that case i was ceo of a media
company that was making tens of millions
of dollars great and and oh also
weirdest what's the weirdest job you've
ever had what's the weird it doesn't
have to be a job what's the weirdest way
you've ever made money
i was a skateboard instructor at the
ymca
that's a good one or the hot dog stand i
think it's a great one also for them all
right a hot dog stand yeah um so so you
take that and you say all right and
everybody has some version of this
everybody has an answer to these
questions
then then you say all right within that
what's the story people don't know about
staining decks or what some people think
people don't realize about about those
hot dog stands you see
and then they're like well you know they
don't and you're so it's kind of like
you said the knowledge complex whatever
it's like you're so in the weeds
you don't remember what it's like to not
know so you kind of got to talk to
somebody about it just say it all out
and you see when they raise their
eyebrows or when they get curious it's
like that's your hook
you need to know like you know how much
those hot dogs really cost or like
where the heck do they go when the game
is over right like you know okay now i
want to know like you know yeah i have
always wanted that so oh wow you put it
in this area whatever um and so so i
think that's what you want to do to come
up with great content ideas you don't
have to be chris pronger and nhl star
who made 100 million dollars i bet you
could have done
maybe not as successful maybe not like
you know 100 000 followers and like one
tweet or whatever you did for that guy
but like i bet if you worked for three
months with somebody who's a
completely normal person like you know
project manager at deloitte
i bet you could get them to 30 or 40 000
followers on twitter within a month
and if you look at well look at so you
didn't have a following on
twitter like three years ago you started
right two years ago yeah
two years ago now you've got over two
hundred thousand trunk fam the guy who
worked for me for a long time when we
when he started
working at my company i think we helped
or he signed up for twitter now he's got
what three or four or 500 or something
yeah 500 000 and then there's like loads
of employees at my company that have
done it like it's very easy to do
yeah exactly all right let's do a
different one um
[Music]
what would you say to a lawyer with a
very i'm a lawyer with a very good
salary what would you say would be a
great answer to motivate me to leave my
cushy but soul-sucking job and jump into
entrepreneurship if my boss asks i'm
asking for a friend
i would say don't jump into
entrepreneurship and get happy with your
job if you're someone that needs another
person to give you motivation to bail
you're you shouldn't bail you're only
doing it because you think that
people think that it's cool because
people they admire do it i would say
don't do it
i don't think that you're the
personality type that this that will be
happy doing this if you need someone to
motivate you
yeah exactly uh and by the way there's a
trick there which is if that pisses you
off it makes you want to do it cool you
are an entrepreneur go ahead you know
you may pass go you may collect your 200
if not like
if that answer feels so wrong for you it
doesn't sit well with you and it annoys
you that sam even said it and you get
this like random chip on your shoulder
for no reason like yeah you kind of are
that's that actually did get you going
on the right path
and also if you're if you're a lawyer i
do think that the hours lawyer works
lawyers work are ridiculous but you
could make a lot of money and i bet
there's a world where you could do like
a nine to five
legal business or be a lawyer and have a
really good life so like why bail if you
if you're not compelled to do it enough
that you're just gonna do it maybe don't
just don't bail be happy
yeah
for sure uh all right pick another one
um would you
uh
would you
consider buying an existing business and
growing it or would you only want to
start things from scratch
frankly i don't know why i haven't done
that like it's pretty clear to me now
that that is a better path for
entrepreneurship
um
[Music]
unless you really just have the killer
idea
um but for some reason i haven't done it
yet i just keep starting new things from
scratch i think there's some fun in that
and
it's not really the logical decision
it's more of the emotional decision
but i for sure would and in fact think i
should
be doing that because
i know how to run a good business i know
how to grow businesses
and taking something that's already
doing 5 10 15 million dollars a year and
getting it to 50
would be a lot easier for me than
getting something from zero to 50 and um
so why not yeah i said makes sense i
just don't get
i don't maybe i'll do it one day i i i
know people talk about this all the time
i agree that it is actually easier and i
agree that the likelihood is better and
your life would in most cases be better
i can't
i just don't give a [__] about something
that someone else made i i enjoy
starting it i i think that to me
building a business is like my art and i
i like doing it from the ground level
and what about okay i got a question for
you from uh from twitter here so john
williams
asks how hard should i should you be
willing to work to create a successful
business is it an 80 hour a week job is
expecting to only work 40 hours a week
unrealistic and by the way his tagline
is john williams [__] work let's play um
i think we know what even what he's
trying to do here um so let me just say
this when i started my company the first
two or three years i was working
constantly all the time and
people would be like what do you mean
like you're in the office you're
thinking about it obviously
i would get to the office at 8 or 9 a.m
and i would go home at 7 or 8 pm
um and i i would dick around at the
office and hang out my employees but i
it was really important to me that i was
the first to arrive and last to leave
and i didn't i didn't expect
i would work sunday evening but not
saturday
so that's like this let's take that you
know as as uh
literally what you said so let's say 12
hours a day
five days a week that's 60 hours a week
plus maybe a couple hours of the weekend
so maybe 64 hours or something like that
in a week
yeah but i couldn't sustain that so i
only did that for like the first two
years and to get to like profitability
and hiring people and then i was able to
to where it was like some weeks it was
80 other weeks it was pretty chill it
was 40. um and uh so i was able to relax
a little bit more um one time i took a
month off so i was able to like but that
was we were making like eight million
dollars that year so um i was able to
chill a little bit um if i had to start
something again i would expect that i
would work 40 or 50 hours a week getting
it going but here's the thing whenever
even now even though i'm not like
actively involved in building a business
i i think about this type of stuff 24
hours a day people ask us sean if we
prepare all the time and i'm like
yeah kinda but also not kinda but like
we're like everything we read it's like
we're relating it back to this trade of
i don't know what you call this thing
improving ourselves and sometimes making
money by doing it yeah
yeah it's like what's that um
i want to keep referencing this like
douchey uh this story that makes me
sound like a douche it's like picasso's
at a restaurant and somebody comes up
and they're like
will you make a piece of art for me and
he grabs a napkin and he scribbles on it
and he's like you know that'll be 30 000
or whatever she's like but you just you
just made that in two seconds and he's
like no this this ma'am like you know
this took me 20 years or whatever to
make this scribble um and that's how i
feel about the podcast like there are
days where i will show up
and it's like wait are you you know what
are you guys talking about like right
before the pod i'll be like hey i'm
gonna go record my wife what are you
guys going to talk about today
i was like i have no idea
and it's not that i have no idea i have
a long list of things that throughout
the week i'm writing down here because
i'm doing calls with all these
interesting people that i'm researching
this thing and if i'm watching a
documentary i'm taking notes it's like
i'm doing things that the average person
doesn't do
in order to generate a bunch of ideas so
that when i show up
it can just be natural i can just speak
naturally about interesting topics
because i've already put in the whole
week of trying to learn interesting
things
and have interesting conversations and
all that stuff so um and i would say
like if if you know a lot of this these
questions are like career advice listen
if you can find a way to do that in your
career you've won which is basically
there's no separation there's no
separation between the things you're
most interested in and liking to do and
spending your nights kind of like
learning about or experimenting with
like find a way for money to be the
byproduct like the exhaust coming out
the chimney of that factory of
interestingness and like that's it i
have heard that before yeah that's
pretty good right
that was that was that was that was
great that's really good yeah
and so i'm a little in awe of that
oh hell yeah all right great put it on a
t-shirt um
i had heard things like that before
but again it was just crack and egg
watching other people crack eggs advice
finally when i did it it's like this is
the way this is for sure the way which
is
just go for the most interesting things
and then
learn core business skills so that you
can turn
you just doing what's most interesting
to you on a daily basis into a
profitable money making event like
venture and then you basically are
funding yourself to live exactly the
life you want
and how long were you working when you
uh at bibo
six seven years something like that
but uh sorry i meant early on how many
hours oh i was i would work a lot but it
was more like
i don't necessarily know if that was
productive like i was at the office
every day from let's call i would get
there like 9 9 30 usually
and then i would leave either like
8 p.m or i would sleep there because
there was like an apartment built into
the office and i was a single guy i
didn't mat like who cares if i go home
to my apartment or i sleep in this
apartment like sleeping here saves me
time and i could just keep you know
working on stuff
and basically what i would do the way i
thought about my day was like
i had decided when i took the job i go
i'm going to work here instead of
starting my own company i'm going to
work here i'm going to pack like 20
years of experience into the next four
years that was my goal right
and then i said okay well how am i going
to do that i said all right well my day
job needs to give me reps
working on startups and like trying to
build them and grow them because that's
the thing i like to do
and then basically as soon as like
everyone would leave the office around
five i would walk out i would go get
like like you know westfield mall was
like right there i'd walk to western
mall walk to the food court that's why i
gained a bunch of weight i'd walk to the
food court i'd be like
tired super hungry i'd go eat some
shitty food in the food court i'd come
back to the office
and then i would like
like i'd have my night job and my night
job was basically like
what are the most interesting companies
who are the most interesting people how
do i like learn about what they're doing
how do i meet them how do i invite them
over for a beer right now at the office
or dinner right now at my office and
like pick their brain on what they're
doing and basically i would build my
network and i'd build my knowledge at
night or i would like build my skills so
i'd like teach myself sql overnight i'm
like okay i'm tired of asking the
developers to run queries for me i'm
gonna learn how to write my own queries
and like you know so i would like spend
two weeks just trying to learn secrets
and then i would spend two weeks really
like studying up on like you know how
mlms grow and like just like i just
picked these like intensives and i would
just go down them so now i kind of have
a whole bunch of obscure knowledge but
because i like dedicated a period of my
life to really only learning about those
things i didn't didn't do other stuff
but it's okay i was like you know
happy as a clam just to do those things
that's badass i think that's a really
good answer um
all right let me pick one what are your
biggest regrets
what past time do you
sorry all right what are your biggest
regrets in business and life what past
time in your life do you miss most what
future time do you most look forward to
so i'll answer really quick my biggest
regret i wish i would have taken my work
my school my sports more seriously as a
young person so like in grade school
high school and college i kind of
dismissed it i wish i would have like
taken it why yeah
because i think that like i
well when you're in high school and
college like there's a time where all
you have to do is acquire skills and
like get good at stuff and i like would
just i didn't like eat well uh i didn't
like sleep as much as i should have for
when it was as relates to sports i
didn't train as hard as i could have
trained and that's just like a period of
time when you're young from like the
ages of 12 to like 20 or 22 if you're a
college athlete which i was for a little
while where it's like you can just get
good at a sport also with school i kind
of [__] off in high school and i
actually regret that i wish i would have
like took the time to learn you know i'm
getting paid to read books now or i'm
i'm sorry i have all my free times to
read books now i read my free time so i
wish i would have taken my
my schooling and my um athletics a lot
more seriously because that's like the
only time you have to do that and uh
i
uh
i'm most looking forward to having
children
nice
all right uh
it's great it's a great answer what's
your favorite
isn't this question really hard to
answer like a regret question like
i feel stuck when i try to answer this
question well what do you think about
all the time and you're like man i wish
i would have had i wish i would have
behaved differently during that period
of my life
so i kind of let me break it up into two
different groups there's like knowing
what i know now oh wow like i could have
done so much better
maybe made more of the opportunity
whether that's like
you know paid my parents basically paid
a bunch of money for me to go to duke
it's like an expensive ass school and
it's got like tons of like you know
opportunity i think there was like this
thing that came out which was like in
the in one in like 2007 on on duke's
campus there was founders of like i
think seven or eight like billion dollar
companies
um so like i was there
um i didn't know any of these people i
didn't even think about entrepreneurship
i didn't think about like meeting i
didn't even think about like wow i'm on
this campus with a bunch of really
awesome people like i should go not just
try to make friends and party but like
who are the people who are actually
working like trying to do something
interesting you know who are those
people who okay i'm just like focused on
my classes and passing them but like why
don't i actually focus on figuring out
what classes are interesting to me right
there's a whole bunch of ways i would do
college differently if i had like had
the wisdom i have today it's not really
like a regret though like when i hear
the word regret i think about like
that word you said behavior where did i
where do i feel like i kind of let
myself down in my behavior and the only
things that come to mind are like any
time that i've been like lower integrity
so like either lying to somebody
exaggerating to somebody um
kind of making a selfish move or like i
got some benefit and other people didn't
really get a benefit
there's not like a big one that comes to
mind but there's like really small ones
that come to mind i think those are my
only regrets like
uh the ones that you don't sleep well
and you're not proud of like a simple
test i do is like
if everybody knew about this move i was
making would i would that be a thing i'm
excited about
like if i could magically get
distribution and everybody knew this
about me would this be something i'd be
proud of or embarrassed of um or neutral
and it's like basically anything that's
in neutral i'm like why don't i just do
it more interestingly you know like let
me just take the comment and make it
more uncommon like that would be all
that and so that's helped me a lot and
the things that i'm embarrassed of it's
like that's just a sign i shouldn't be
doing this and i need to like bite the
bullet and like reverse course on this
and like i think before i used to
definitely be like an exaggerator
white liar like kind of like
not like nothing that harmed people but
like definitely things that like
benefited me
and like over time i've like tried to
stamp those out um so i would say like
just little stupid things like that
would be the only things that i actually
regret whereas everything else it's like
i don't know like yeah i was dumb i
didn't know things at that time and
whatever you know who cares i learned
them by doing the thing the wrong way i
learned the right way
there was one time when i was 18 and
like uh a limo or i was like in a
shuttle from the hotel to like on a
college visit or something like that and
the man driving the bus was
the little you know it's like a van when
you're at the marriott and they take you
around and
he was like all right you're at your
stop and i you're supposed to tip him
sometimes and i tipped him five dollars
he goes oh no it's okay and i said oh no
you need this and i meant to say
like you earned it or something and i
said you need this
and that's one of those things that i
look back and i'm like i cannot believe
that was so condescending of me i cannot
believe that's something i think about
all the time i'm like i can't believe i
said that i cannot believe that's that's
one of my big regrets dude i have like
10 of those
have i told the orlando bloom story on
here
no people make fun of me because i tell
the story so often if i haven't told her
i'm gonna tell you now okay here's one
of my biggest regrets
so
uh i'm in london i'm 21 years old maybe
and my buddy comes to visit uh for
college and so i i was living in london
at the time my parents up there and like
so i'm like okay let's go out now i
hadn't really gone out in london so i
didn't kind of know where to go i didn't
know the protocols the etiquettes i just
been kind of hanging out with my parents
at their house i wasn't drinking i
didn't have a big tolerance at this time
uh you know like i basically hadn't
still don't
yeah still don't
didn't have big towers back then still
don't have it
my buddy comes to visit and i'm like all
right i want to be cool with with his
buddy uh shout out to my buddy goops if
he's listening he he'll know this is him
so we go out and london i'm trying to
act cool because i'm like he thinks i
live in the center of london he thinks i
still kind of like go out like i did in
college he doesn't know i've just been
in my mom's apartment you know like
doing nothing for like three months you
know just like i don't know watching
reruns of lost and so uh so i'm like oh
let's go over here let's go over here
i'm like oh this place is popping
because i see a place just with a line
outside i'm like this is the place we're
going here he's like you sure we can
just go to this bar i'm like no no we're
going over here so we go to this place
lying outside and he's like i don't
think this is like a bar club it turns
out it's a theater and i'm like oh [__]
but i'm like kind of pot committed to my
like plan of like no no this place is
the the best i've now picked a theater
like a
place but the plane just ended people
were waiting outside i'm like
and there's this group of girls they
were all visiting for the university of
georgia
and uh duke university has like uh kind
of notoriously like um not the hottest
college girls and so these girls to me
were like a 14 out of 10. and so um and
so
and they probably didn't have the
hottest guys
either yeah right like
i was a strong seven at duke
i'm a three-year-old
private school seven public school three
and so
you know i'm a state school of three so
so basically um i'm like okay i'm trying
to still trying to recover from groups
being like why are you telling me to go
to this theater and i'm like because i
want to talk to these girls and so now
i'm like trying to act cool for these
girls which was i was already failing
and acting cool in front of my dude
brown friend now i'm trying to focus for
this girl so i'm like you're like the
tinder swindler man of your friend group
so i'm like what are we doing here what
are we waiting for and they're like oh
the other you know
the play just ended and orlando bloom
did a drop in at the show and so he's
coming out and like we're all just
waiting for his autograph face to take a
picture of him
and i'm like in my head i'm like
like you okay do you know who orlando
bloom is if i say that do you know the
who who that is because you have a
picture in your head i know exactly who
he is okay i didn't so i'm like i've
heard the name but i'm like i have no
idea who this guy is or why he's famous
but like clearly he's famous as a crowd
here waiting for him and so we're
waiting 20 minutes and i'm just chopping
it up with these girls and so what year
was this
this would have been uh i don't know 13
14 years ago so like dude so orlando was
like peak orlando bloom like exactly
he's just done pirates of the caribbean
i didn't i didn't know how to connect it
and i couldn't ask because i'd already
again told troops we got to go here told
these girls i'm waiting for orlando
bloom they don't know that i don't know
who he is but anyways we're just kind of
shooting the [__] because i have this
captive audience these girls can't leave
they're waiting for orlando bloom so
they gotta talk to me basically at this
point so we're having fun we're flirting
with these girls things are going well
now so my night has turned around
but
problem is
people are coming out from the plane i
don't know who orlando bloom is so i'm
just sort of waiting to see where the
reaction comes from
i'm expecting like i don't know
brad pitt and his prime i'm expecting
like you know bruce willis i'm expecting
just like some like
just some hunk to come out because like
clearly all these women are waiting for
him
lando is pretty pretty hunky man
he's pretty good person he's a lot more
like um
petite petite exactly the word i'm
looking for so this guy walks out and
he's just this kind of small guy and
he's got this
wispy body in this wispy mustache
and i'm like this is the [__] guy and
so like i'm just sort of like i'm a
little bit drunk i'm pretty drunk at
this point i'm just like oh my god so
he's facing these exciting autographs
for the other people he's about to get
into this car this limo
and like there wasn't a lot of space you
know like the distance between me and my
kind of like like you know this window
in front of me is two feet away that's
how far he was away and he's just not
turning around to like
sign our autographs or whatever i don't
want his autograph but somebody just tap
him on the shoulder
orlando
orlando and like i'm screaming his name
and so i said it like kind of like
medium and then he doesn't turn and so
then i'm just drunk so i'm like i'm just
going to say this loud as i can so i'm
yelling and americans are already like
40 louder than europeans and now i'm
trying to be loud and so
he's he's not american right now but
so he probably doesn't like that either
nobody liked it nobody liked it trust me
like these girls who i was shocked they
were like oh my god this is so
off-putting why is this man so loud
right now and so um it sounds like i'm
just screaming and i am screaming he
turns around and i just go orlando and
he turns i go
and i'd see his face for the first time
i've only seen a petite body from behind
which is basically a woman's body so he
turns around and they see his mustache i
go
what's with the stash
i thought it was from the play i thought
he had left it on because it looks so
ridiculous
and so he's like he just sort of rolls
his eyes and the girls are like you're
the most uncool
dude on the planet now you've annoyed
orlando
and he just like he starts walking into
he just he just sort of aborts and the
girls are pissed because he didn't like
acknowledge them now either the whole
section got blacklisted so he gets in
the car
trust me that's not the worst of it he
gets on the car this is where the story
ends in the in the the final crescendo
and i'm like and something comes over me
i'm like you know i'm like a
entrepreneur i'm action oriented i'm a
go-getter so i decided to be a go-getter
with orlando bloom and i go to the car
and there's no security because again
nobody expects a buffoon to just like
open up the car door so i i reach
through the window he's waving
bye to the fans through the through the
back seat i reach through the passenger
front seat into the back seat while he's
waving and my hand just wraps around his
um like i was going for like a high five
but i'm he's waving so it's a moving
target i only catch his thumb
have you ever had another man's thumb
inside your full hand
yes one of the most uncomfortable
feelings yeah i immediately sober up he
looks at me like yo bro like
why are you like why are you grabbing my
phone and i'm just like
i was like dude i'm so sorry and i just
i let it go
and i let go of the whole night and i
basically it's the most embarrassing
thing that i've done
um you know since then it's never done
never topped that moment
so that's my biggest regret oh my god
that's awesome grabbing orlando bloom's
thumb as he drove away after making fun
of his mustache if orlando if you if
you're listening to this if if your
cousin is listening to send this to
orlando let him know
that guy you know he was just
he was just trying to impress his friend
you know he was just trying to be i
don't know what he was trying to do but
it was an accident i didn't know we know
you're trying to do you're doing it for
the tail whatever everyone's been there
he would empathize with that um do i
don't think we should do any more i
think we have to end on that that was
awesome that was the best story i've
heard in a long time
[Laughter]
all right fantastic good uh good q a
just the tips uh from your boys
just the tips all right we're out of
here
[Music]
you